from a director whose main qualification
for spider-man is his last name comes a
spider-man 2 with the spider-man 3 level
of quality the amazing spider-man 2 hey
didn't cinemasins already do this one
you've already seen that premature
reboot to the original trilogy now
before you see the solo spin off to the
soft reboot crossover revisit the crappy
sequel to the premature reboot that
failed so hard Spidey swung back over to
Marvel then unfortunately back over to
Sony again
not a great plan lower your expectations
because the same guys who wrote star
trek into darkness and a bunch of bad
Michael Bay movies are back and you can
bet they'll be ruining something you
loved as a kid while including magic
blood at some point once we caught on my
synthesize the serum from his super
blood in spider-man's
blood in a movie that's so bloated black
cat and Spider Slayer only get cameos
while endings nursing career has its own
plot line double ship from Thursday it
has to take nursing classes with 22 year
old kids so I can take you to vote a
colleague who asked for this returned to
a New York where everyone exclusively
uses Sony products crowds cheer while
Violent Crimes play out and everyone in
the city is a scientific genius except
at bay me just stupid non-scientific
ant and say hello hello to Peter Parker
who's corrected his stutter from the
first movie um so you want to uh I don't
know we could I don't we could off and
replaced it with constantly repeating
himself as the question
that's question wait wait wait
stay with me stay with me stay there
with me stay with me
watch his relationship with Gwen Stacy
grow from loving her so much they have
to stay together against her dead dad's
wishes don't make promises you can't
keep with your partner was the best kind
to loving her so much that they had to
stay apart sorry Glen so loving her so
much that they had to stay together
again with a healthy dose of stalking in
between have you ever fallen just once a
day I'm pretty small I'm following you
now I'm just going to follow you
everywhere thrill as spider-man faces
off against electro a villain who
combines Milton from office space with a
tumblr slash fiction blog you like
that's right when he falls into a tank
of eels he'll get a random grab bag of
electric powers like magneto iing Force
Lightning invisibility and electric
cosmetic dentistry but for some reason
no actual eel powers I paid good money
to watch Jamie Foxx built and asked for
his eggs out of his own saliva
that's an eel fact look it up grill as
everyone forgets the lesson of
spider-man 3 and crams even more
villains into an already packed movie
like the Green Goblin again who's in a
frantic rush to cure the diseases dad
lived with for 60 years oh hi when
Stacy's ghosts dad and the Rhino
Oh a ridiculous Russian transformer who
begins in in fulfill my crab bread on a
poop sandwich so settle in for a
spider-man movie with a good performance
by Andrew Garfield that was so bogged
down by subplots underwhelming action
trailer moments with no payoff and the
constant stink of desperation to create
a cinematic universe that writer Alex
Kurtzman did it all over again with a
mummy seriously how does that happen
starring Oh Tom Holland oh snap mr.
burns deign to hug and aahs dr.
Manhattan and Tobey Maguire spider-man
to electro Boogaloo Tom Holland is great
no but I'll miss Andrew Garfield maybe
he could be cooling Uncle Ben and get
shot by Tobey Maguire and then he can
fly away in the Japanese spider Zord now
that's the cinematic universe I could
get behind guys screen junkies is going
to comic-con we'll be covering the whole
event live on screen Nicky's news but
bigger than ever we're throwing our own
event live Saturday July 22nd at House
of Blues in San Diego we had some
amazing celebrities lined up who you
were not going to miss you can get
tickets now at screen junkies calm slash
tickets that's right go pick them up
before they're gone but I know a lot of
you are like but I'm not in San Diego
how am I going to be able to do this
don't worry we got you covered
we're throwing a sweepstakes we will
bring out you and a friend put you up
fly you up to join us there in person
it's going to be so epic do not miss
this opportunity and get excited for
street hockey special 2017 thanks to the
new Samsung Chromebook plus for helping
make this possible
grab a bob there's going to be guts on
the ceiling let me get a boneless pizza
they call him Baba Yaga
Megamind is better than Despicable Me
and wreck-it Ralph